man do i love this film available
now today 4k ultra hd and blu-ray
as well as on digital uh i cannot
believe this film was
1987. so
33 years ago is when fullmetal jacket
first hit theaters in stanley kubrick
one of his finest films and uh did an
amazing job in this and so many other
great tv and film
uh that i've enjoyed him and pleased to
have to talk about full metal jacket and
more
matthew modine how are you matthew i'm
doing very well thank you richard
oh thanks for i have to get you a i'm
gonna have to get you a matthew modine
mug
there for the for your collection okay
what is on the matthew modine mug
what is on the mug here that i could put
on my desk
well i don't actually have a matthew
mode
i didn't mean to call you out i mean uh
okay i'll just because i want to be on
that
that cup shelf of okay
so maybe maybe is there do you have any
what what is do you have an item from
full metal jacket that you still have
that uh that that you're proud of having
do you still have any do you have
anything from that
movie senator yeah i have a mickey mouse
watch
and uh the piece button from my uh
my uh that i wore throughout the vietnam
section of the film
my piece button and the mickey mouse
watch where you were called out for
wondering if that's a
your version of a sick joke correct from
that film yeah
yeah actually i forgot i also have my
glasses i have a pair of
those glasses i mean it is such a
it is such a classic film matthew and i
just want to start i guess with the
broad question of what it was like to be
in the employee if you will uh of
stanley kubrick
for that movie wait wait you know i
can't compare the experience of working
on full metal jacket with any of the
other experiences i've had working on
films just because of the sheer length
of time
my wife and i were in england my son was
born there it was about
uh almost 22 months almost two years of
of of being in england with uh with with
mr kubrick
and the experience was extraordinary he
uh the good news is that there's an app
there's called full metal jacket diary
it was a book and then it was made into
an app
by one of the geniuses at apple computer
a young man named adam rakoff
he took the assets that were in my book
my diary
and the photos and he did high-res scans
of them and then had me record the
the the the well i guess let's call it
the dialogue in the book
uh and he made it into this amazing
award-winning
what they call a appumentary that's free
right now to celebrate the release of
the
the book so if you have an ipad if you
can borrow an ipad
the ipad app full metal jacket diary is
free right now
so that kind of covers all of the the
stories that that i had while i was
making
the film and and it's from the point of
view of a young 24 25 year old
kid who's gone off to work with arguably
one of the greatest film directors to
ever get behind a motion picture camera
so and again it had been
seven years since his previous film it
was his previous film was the shining he
had not
put out a film since that classic and
now here he is
putting his take if you will on the
vietnam war experience
uh what did he do to you guys on the set
to make you feel like you were really in
the you-know-what
well he wasn't like a method director
and and uh the only person who was kind
of
liked that i think was vincent d'onofrio
who who kind of
uh went into character and kind of
stayed in character
he played private pile uh who
you know shoots himself in the latrine
at the end of the that first boot camp
sequence
um but but stanley kubrick uh
to everybody's shock and sometimes
dismay
was uh not a horrible mean
person he was cruel but he was fair um
that you know he said the reason he has
to do so many takes is because
uh so often times actors don't know
their lines
and when when he says that he doesn't
mean that they don't
you know they haven't memorized them and
show up and and repeat their lines
that knowing their lines uh had to be
something that was
uh as uh unconscious
as you know a marine recruit who could
take apart their rifle and put it back
together with a blindfold on
that you you had to you had to really
understand what it was you were saying
to the point where there was no other
logical thing for you to say
even dr even lee ermey who played the
drill instructor
uh had to work on memorizing lines
that he had contributed to the script
you know the these were
these these were things that he said
that were written down and put into the
script
but then he had to memorize them as an
actor would to be able to repeat them
over and over and and from different
angles you know that
a a real journal instructor doesn't uh
doesn't do that
you know which lee army was a real drill
instructor and so he had to
had to go through the processes of of
being able to repeat those lines and
repeat a performance
multiple times with what they call
continuity you know that if if
he reaches up and scratches his head in
the scene and they change the camera
angle
you have to reach up and scratch your
head in the in the in the same fashion
so that you can edit the movie together
with continuity
you've all we've all seen those mistakes
in movies right where
somebody's holding a cup of coffee in
one angle and you cut to another angle
and he's not holding the coffee he's
taking a puff on a cigarette from this
angle and
there's no cigarette in his hand in the
next scene you know
so what would be the average number of
takes you you
you had on full metal jacket with
kubrick well i like to
think of arless howard uh he arliss
played cowboy
in the film he was in boot camp and in
the vietnam sequence
when we get ready to go into the into
that place the square where
the the sniper is picking us off one by
one
so there was a before before there uh
when eight ball gets up and
and goes into the square and gets shot
um we were at
that wall arliss said i don't care if
this is the greatest scene in the
history of movie making
i'm going to tell everybody that i was
at this wall for one month
so that sequence which is probably
i don't know maybe three or four four
minutes of film
we were at the wall for a month get out
of here
i mean do you ever want to say did you
ever want to did you ever want to say to
him
hey uh or she referred to him even here
in 2020 mr kubrick
uh come on we got it did you ever want
to say that at some point
never and he said it early on to me
early on he
invited my wife and i to his house many
times for dinner yes and
uh he said you know isn't it funny how
people say how many takes do
do do i take you know like what
difference does it make how many takes
i i do you know he said would you ever
go to pablo picasso and say hey pablo i
really love that painting how many
strokes
or would you say would you say to
beethoven how many notes in that
symphony
ludwig and you know
when you're in the process of creating
something i mean maybe that's why we're
talking about the movie 33 years after
the fact
is that that what it was i didn't this
elusive thing that he was looking for in
order to be able to move on and say good
cut we got it let's move on um
that elusive thing uh i don't know what
it was i can't tell you why we did that
many takes
but i know that i've done i guess almost
100
projects now and this is the only one
i'm talking about 33 years after the
fact
well it's because my social media grand
masters he likes to call tj jefferson
hasn't asked you his vision quest
question yet uh matthew
he wants to talk about vision quest with
you but but for the moment
you know i still have control of the
microphone you know so um
i i i do have just a couple more
questions
left with you about this we'll turn a
little bit to sports with you matthew
modine here on the rich eisen show
so uh our lee ermey was a real uh drill
sergeant
was he originally slated like this was
his gig from the get-go
or did he he was uh kind of
uh on the show as a con show the film is
a consult
as a consultant and he just grew into
the role how how did that
happen with him yeah so it was another
actor was playing the part
uh tim colcheri and took tim as the guy
who's in the helicopter
shooting women and children you know
when i say get something screaming
children right
yeah yeah get some right uh so that was
tim colcher he was hired for the role in
and we shot vietnam and then boot camp
we shot the movie back to front
and uh lee was the technical advisor on
the movie he was advising
he was a vietnam veteran and he was he
you know teaching making sure that
people were using their rifles correctly
and
you know strategic moving you know
movements uh how how
a uh a platoon of soldiers would come
into that square you know to move
appropriately and you know so he was our
technical advisor
and there were a lot of recruits because
as we were finishing up vietnam and
getting ready to start
uh the boot camp sequence of the film
all of those other uh actors that are in
the background of the scenes
had to be hand-picked and chosen so
they would they would come in to
audition and
lee ermey would audition them and when
stanley looked at the videotape
with lee ermey you know saying thing
you're the kind of guy that suck a
you know you know yes i don't think i
can repeat that is correct
that is correct yeah you know you could
suck a golf ball through a garden hose
yeah i could say that one yes indeed um
so all of that colorful stuff that lee
said
you know stanley started looking at the
videotapes and going
you know my god this guy is the real
deal that i don't
he doesn't have to act he just has to
react to what's happening
in the in the movie and so lee became
our drill instructor and
and tim colcheri bless him you know he's
a terrific actor uh was
was fired and then stanley felt bad and
said hey how about i bring you back can
you play
the door gunner which is a you know he
still gets to participate
in this film but you know it was
devastating for tim
i bet he yeah very devastating
i bet i bet but i mean uh you know lee
ermey was nominated for a golden globe i
don't know how he didn't get a
nomination for an oscar in it
he was that good that believable and
that see those scenes was that the best
shape you ever
were in in your life i imagine matthew
no vision
vision quest no kidding that was the
yeah vision quest of
i mean i had to go probably five weeks
before we began filming
because i didn't know how to wrestle um
i went out for wrestling the wrestling
team my sophomore year in high school
and i said you got to be crazy to do
this sport this that was the hardest
thing i've ever done in my life
and what you realize when anybody who's
participated in that
probably boxing uh is that
your your who you're wrestling against
is yourself
you know how how much are you willing to
endure how much uh
pain are you willing to endure how how
you know how much can you learn to be
able to
you know to outsmart your opponent but
it's it's it's a
it's really uh
an extraordinary sport because you
probably mma is the same thing that
you just learn so much about who you are
and what you're able to endure
and uh so i went yeah about five weeks
before
and we wrestled uh once a day then i
weight trained
and then and then uh running and lifting
weights
so look with the guy the guy that i was
wrestling probably
in real life weighed about 30 pounds
more than me i mean he was that guy was
a beast
and so i was all the whole movie where
i'm supposed to be losing weight i was
actually
trying to put weight on put on put on
muscle weight all the time
while i was making the film never
thought in a million years that you'd be
in better shape vision quest than uh
than the boot camp scenes in full metal
jacket but there you go matthew modine
here
and in terms of boot camp um and you
mentioned just words like how much pain
are you willing to endure
um that those are questions i asked
myself all right you're going to talk
about jim dolan
[Applause]
you're a smart man you're a smart man
it's it's it's definitely questions i
ask myself as a
as a knick fan growing up in uh born in
brooklyn raised in staten island uh
matthew
how much pain are you willing to endure
matthew how much pain
isn't it isn't it weird because there's
been so many moves that you thought
well this is good we got carmelo we got
stodda meyer we got larry johnson i mean
what about phil jackson
phil jackson they get phil jackson run
the team
yeah how did that happen how is it that
we
we made so many good moves that went so
wrong
you know it what happened i mean
what i i it is it is baffling that
that uh that uh
you know it's like standing with
somebody who keeps putting quarters in
the slot machine and never
never wins it's interesting
yes the knicks are a one-armed bandit
basically is what you're saying is there
any
is there any part of you any part of you
that thinks
brooklyn nets aren't a bad uh team to
root for uh like
durant and kyrie i can't do it no i
can't i can't i can't do it
i got kyrie and durant and steve nash is
a coach i mean a beautiful facility or
in brooklyn you can get to it easily
matthew no that's you're not even
thinking of that huh
no that you know it that
like you know the boston fans that had
to suffer for so many years or worse the
chicago fans
that you know with the goat uh that
it just makes it that much sweeter there
was i was listening to sports radio
yesterday and they were talking about
dirt
dirk nowitzki that he could have gone to
so many teams and won a ring
so much earlier but the fact that he
suffered through
those those those years where they
almost almost almost were always there
and then to finally win it it makes it
that much sweeter so
you know sticking with the knicks and
and and hoping
you know that it'll just make it that
much better when they when they do
you know it's like being a mets it's
like being a mets fan right now
so basically what you're saying if i'm
not mistaken
the knicks are your team there's no one
else like it
and that one is yours essentially you
sound you sound like you're talking
about your rifle and full metal jacket
and you won't give it up right
this is my team there are many like it
but this one is mine right
that's it yeah yeah that's right yeah
and then you use another phrase like
you're looking around
you know uh why would you make this
movie none of you dumbasses knows
basically it's another sort of line from
fullmetal jacket trying to figure
out what's going on with the knicks but
you're still sticking with them
god bless you yeah yeah i mean all those
years we suffered with michael jordan
i love him i think i i appreciate him
when he came to the when he came to the
garden all i wanted to do was beat him i
don't know
what was it i assume you saw the last
dance that was for me
as a knick fan reliving the charles
smith moment
reliving that you know when jordan comes
back and he's struggling and he gets the
garden and he
you know he and bill wentington combined
for 57 points
you know um yeah and oh my god
it was tough it was tough to sit through
that because the knicks had it that was
those were the teams matthew that was it
yep
that was it that was it that was it
then we got the pat riley years and now
he's now he's got the heat
two games from the finals again without
lebron maybe to face lebron this could
be it
oh man well look i appreciate you
calling in and ha
commiserating with me uh best you can um
and
uh this what about you you're not gonna
you're not gonna go to the brooklyn nets
i'm done with them matthew i didn't want
to go in this direction because i don't
want to get you in any trouble if you
want to still go to the games
but when the minute oakley got dragged
out of the garden i was finished
i was finished how can he sit there and
watch oakley dragged out of the garden
how can he sit there and not stop it
how can he let him sit there at night in
jail honestly i was done
i was done it's just so difficult but i
grew i grew up in staten island bernard
king was my guy
and yeah and then when bernard um hurt
his knee and the knicks got
ewing because of it i thought here it
comes here comes the bernard and patrick
era and it just never materialized and
but that's my that that was my team that
was my team yeah
i hate to talk but are you a yankee fan
too or you're not
yes yankees yeah okay so they went on a
on a good streak they got
10 wins and now what is it two or three
losses in a row
now they they just lost last night to
toronto um and they i think it's two in
a row
they they finally lost to the red sox
this year which is something evan
brought up to my
boston friend across the aisle for me
here in our show studio this season
doesn't count
i know it doesn't it doesn't count um
but no i'm
i'm looking forward to the playoffs for
sure um yeah
and hey man look um i guess i don't know
to say congratulations to somebody whose
film is out uh
again but uh that i i will definitely
get the ipad appumentary that you're
talking about i can't wait to see all of
it
i can't wait to hear all your stories
and let's let's keep talking come back
on the show whenever you want if you
want to vent
you say you should listen to sports talk
radio i'll have you on matthew from new
york
i appreciate that thank you you got it
right back at you that's matthew modine
at matthew modine on twitter and
instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here